we talked about my testing before um but
so a bare-knuckle fighting championships
the often I'm twenty million dollars
before to come back and fight in their
organization but now they're upping it
they're saying that paying more than
twenty million dollars and they're even
thinking of having them fight Wanderlei
Silva I've gotta watch that what how
much thinking offer I wonder what it's
gonna take to get him back because he's
in shape pretty sure they're even shape
right now would he fight like some like
X UFC fighter who's not he's not able to
speak anymore but they're both out there
bro this sort of like the big three of
fighting yes yes the big three they're
not gold with tight Mike Tyson I don't
care who you bet on lights
oh yeah Mike Rowe knock him out at heart
is that right have you seen Mike lately
shred so [ __ ] and so much faster than
you but you but you got to get a figure
Wanderlei Silva is also gonna be on
whatever Mike Tyson's on yes for sure
Maryland Bentley sylia that face surgery
music yeah this is his fighter classic
hall-of-famer personally I'm fighting to
come to ax murder he's too used to do
this all the time for a fight look crazy
had all these wars and its face because
the scar tissue just started getting
like a shar-pei and then he moved to
Vegas and it was like I'm just gonna get
like the scar tissue removed and got a
full [ __ ] the full getup I was like
well who the [ __ ] is that man look at
Mike's body yeah yeah 52 feel very low
silver before after pictures Brian this
could be you when you get your live
thing ah 16 yeah like man died so you're
gonna do it you're already beautiful
Ryan oh I love you Kat my girls I love
my girl thanks that's kind of one he
looks more like this now yeah yeah
and on the right was him before so this
is how he is now but then the left is
what he looked like before not bad
what's wrong with the left the nose
change his eyes changed a little bit too
young well I Got News for you guys he
had his eyes done yeah yeah definitely
but he said he told everyone he was
going to they're like now he was you got
some work done there I'm gonna tell you
this right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch
your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that
boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]